i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
[Música]
la verdad que es un gusto poder estar
hoy aquí con ustedes
y tengo que decir que el presentador se
equivocó recién porque presentó a
ricardo primo y no presentó a la persona
que está conmigo ustedes la ven
yo a lo mejor no la veo pero la siento
y es mi incertidumbre la incertidumbre
que en este momento tengo de que esto
puede salir bien o puede salir mal que
puedo ser claro o un poco confuso la
incertidumbre de saber de que ustedes se
van a llevar algo positivo de esta
charla quizás no es la misma
incertidumbre de quién está sentado en
la butaca 17 de este teatro
o quien está sentado en la butaca 43 de
este recinto pero es la incertidumbre e
incertidumbre que nació con el ser
humano la incertidumbre que tenían
aquellos que salían a cazar a pescar en
esas sociedades primitivas cuando surgió
la humanidad porque ellos tenían
incertidumbre acerca de lo que ocurría a
su alrededor había truenos terremotos
lluvias
frío y no sabían explicar todos estos
sucesos entonces empezaron a decir de
que eran causa de un ser superior
crearon los dioses de la lluvia de la
guerra de la muerte de la vida del sol
de la luna un panteón de dioses y
surgieron las religiones y las
religiones trazaron en esas sociedades
primitivas relaciones de poder con las
personas que eran gobernadas por
sacerdotes por hechiceros o por magos el
mundo giraba en torno a ese tipo de
relación
pero también después
aparece un solo dios el dios que todo lo
sabe el dios que todo lo explica
y de las religiones politeístas pasamos
a la religión monoteísta un solo dios
todo lo sabe
y comenzó el imperio de la fe en la
humanidad pero la fe a veces no daba
respuestas a ciertas inquietudes que
tenían las personas y esas inquietudes
sobrevivían en el mundo de la religión y
hubo personas que tenían incertidumbre
de lo que venía una incertidumbre o una
inseguridad de no poder explicar muchas
de las cosas que ocurrían
y así aparece la ciencia la lucha de la
razón contra la fe el mundo religioso
entra un poco en crisis porque la razón
busca una explicación distinta a la
explicación basada en el dogma religioso
en la fe es un camino difícil de choque
si no pregunten a galileo galilei que
tuvo que adjurar de su teoría y decir
que estaba equivocado porque si no
terminaba la hoguera
la ciencia a través de un método
científico a través de una explicación
de una hipótesis de una investigación
trata de encontrar soluciones y a veces
nosotros creemos que la solución
científica es la mejor y no nos damos
cuenta de que también está abriendo la
puerta a nuevas incertidumbres y le voy
a contar lo que me pasó en mi vida en un
momento en que yo tenía casi todo
resuelto tenía certeza sobre mi vida
un 16 o 17 de enero de 2017 mi pueblo se
inundó
fue un momento muy difícil para toda la
población la ciencia la historia me
había indicado que el máximo de caudal
de agua dentro de una vivienda había
llegado a 80 centímetros entonces yo
había tomado las previsiones que el
conocimiento histórico me lo daba y
levanté todo lo que pude a 80
centímetros pero tuve un metro 30 de
agua
mi casa se inundó por completo con esa
inundación perdí todos mis archivos toda
mi biblioteca de historia
fue un momento muy difícil porque para
un historiador perder sus archivos sus
libros es como perder la memoria
imagínense un cirujano si pierde sus
manos
o un cantante si pierde su voz
las cosas materiales se pueden reponer
pero el trabajo de 25 años los apuntes
los manuscritos todo lo que había
producido uno en su vida se perdió para
siempre incluso la información que
tenían mis computadoras porque era agua
y barro y eso daño lo disco rígido y no
lo pude recuperar más
esto me sumo en la depresión
durante mucho tiempo
me di cuenta de que no había una certeza
sobre las cosas
y entonces salía a caminar con mi esposa
buscando un sentido a la vida qué hacer
con mi vida de ahora en más y miraba
hacia el horizonte
en la búsqueda de una respuesta
y sobre
no me da pena ni vergüenza decirlo
porque no sabía que iba a ser con mi
vida con mi futuro y dije no puede ser
de que este tipo de cosas me esté
ocurriendo cuando ya creía que estaba
todo solucionado y me prometí que esa
debilidad
tenía que convertirla en fortaleza que
tenía que seguir adelante
comencé entonces a digitalizar todo
libro de historia principalmente local y
regional que caía en mis manos pero no
una simple digitalización fue una
digitalización acompañada con un
programa un software de reconocimiento
de caracteres o texto de manera tal de
que yo ingreso al elemento digitalizado
pongo una palabra clave y me lo busca
entre el centenar de páginas y me dice
dónde está de manera tal de que ese
libro digitalizado interactúa con otro
libro contenido en una carpeta formaban
datos contenidos sobre otra base mucho
más grande un metadatos de esa manera yo
evitaba tener que ir a una biblioteca a
buscar un libro sacarlo mirar el índice
comenzar a leerlo para encontrar la
información que ahora le iba a tener en
segundos y hoy tengo una super
biblioteca digitalizada que me permite
dar respuesta en forma eficiente rápida
y múltiple a los requerimientos de
información y esto incluso me permitió
asesorar al municipio para implementar
las ciertas áreas donde se manejan
volúmenes de información tan grande que
requieren ser utilizadas lo antes
posible y eso tardaría tiempo
y me dije no me tengo que quedar con
esto tengo que ir por más y entonces
comencé a cruzar datos de las efemérides
de los hechos que habían ocurrido en el
pasado
y lo subí a mi calendario del celular
así que yo simplemente con mirar mi
celular tengo la información de todo lo
que ocurrió en esta ciudad por ejemplo
un día como hoy ustedes lo están viendo
en pantalla un 3 de noviembre
así que mi vida también cambió a partir
de ese momento y les puedo decir lo
siguiente
hoy por hoy después de todo lo que he
pasado
tenemos muchas incertidumbres por
delante pero hay una sola certeza la que
no da la vida el ser humano nace vive y
muere es la única certeza infalible en
cada paso nuestro tenemos por delante el
incertidumbre pero esa incertidumbre nos
abre las puertas para salir de la misma
nos abre una oportunidad para encarar un
nuevo camino y poder afrontar esa
inseguridad que vive junto a nosotros
debemos concebir al conocimiento como
algo que no tiene límites
que podemos mejorar aún de lo peor
y por sobre todas las cosas a todos
ustedes le digo
el mayor aprendizaje que me dejó todo
esto es que siempre pero siempre vamos a
tener que saber convivir con nuestra
incertidumbre muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]